what's going on here is uh this is the
Bank of England's uh official rate and
that's where we are at the moment 2.25
so two two and a quarter percent and
what I'm going to show you here is kind
of where markets and Traders people
within the market expected it to go uh
in the coming years so this is where the
expectation was uh back in February so I
mean it's kind of extraordinary isn't it
to think about how much things have
changed since then back then uh people
who were making bets on this stuff only
thought they was going to go up to 1.75
and inflation was already starting to
kind of rear its head at that point but
look at what's happened since then so
what we're looking into the future here
over the future uh what people think is
going to happen to interest rates that
was in February then it went up to about
2.75 in August remember this is just
expectations but this feeds in to the
mortgage costs that we're all paying
because it goes into something called
swaps rates uh you're talking about the
kind of costs that mortgage lenders look
at when they're working out how to price
their mortgages and then by early
September obviously we had the new Liz
trust government by that point no one
was 100 percent sure what they were
going to do clearly as it turned out but
by then already the cost of borrowing in
terms of the expectations where it was
going was up to 4.75 for bank rate uh
next year so you can see this getting
higher and higher and higher the cost of
Brian going higher even before the mini
budget but look at what happened next so
then came the midi budget and then last
week that went up to a peak of 6.1
percent I'll show you in a second why
that matters so much the good news is
since then it has come down a fair uh
bit well I say a fair bit it's in
between the two at the moment it's about
5.5 is where markets currently expect
those rates to go and that could
obviously yo-yo around but the big
difference is really the comparison with
where we were only at the start of the
year and where we are now that's a big
difference and when you look and
basically look at what's available in
the markets you see that that stuff's
actually already starting to feed
through so what this is just showing you
is a moment ago Jane was talking about
the kind of average rate that's
available on a two-year fixed rate
mortgage well this is basic clear it
going all the way back to 2008 and you
can see look around
2007-2008 it was up at around six seven
percent so really high in comparison
with where it was subsequently the era
of cheap money cheap mortgages uh in
comparison with much of history but look
at what's happened recently it was
climbing up before this mini budget
before Liz trust was elected it was
getting up to around that kind of four
percent Mark but look what happened
subsequently look at that line now up to
6.07 it's actually kind of a little bit
uh potentially since then and that is
the highest that we've seen since 2008
and here's why that's significant as
Jane was saying a second ago it's not
just about this race it's also about
other factors it's about how much debt
you have it's about how high your income
is in comparison with your mortgage
repayments and that shows your ability
to repay it that's the important thing
so the chart we really need to look at
is not that it's an affordability chart
and I've got one here as it so happens
which shows you the mortgage burden and
the higher this line is basically the
more of your income you're paying on
your mortgage each month this is for New
Deals okay and the couple of things to
note here okay that was just before the
last financial crisis really getting
pretty high there
um that was the period in the late 80s
early 90s before we had an enormous
housing crash negative equity it was
really a really terrible time probably
the most Torrid housing Christ crisis
we've had in this uh in this country but
look here it was really low recently you
know we've been living through quite a
kind of you know fortunate time in terms
of mortgage payments um but look at what
happens subsequently so before before
the many budget uh these rates in terms
of the available rates out there and how
much they dig into your income that have
risen to the highest level since 2008 so
it was already getting quite high but
then look what happened next okay then
came the mini budget and that went up to
the highest level that we've seen since
the early uh 1990s late 1980s up to
about 27 of your income and that's the
real concern it's the fact that we're
looking at the burden remember we he had
similar charts to this when we're
looking at Energy prices just how much
they were digging into your average
income
it's the same thing with the mortgages
Jane and I think that's the issue you
know we've already been talking about a
cost of living crisis for quite some
time but now there's this mortgage
element on top of the energy bit on top
of the fact that inflation's really high
and that people are quite squeezed at
the moment